[Musique]
l'aurore boréale connu également sous le
nom de lumière du nord est l'un des
phénomènes de mère nature les plus
spectaculaires même si la chance ne vous
attend pas forcément au tournant si vous
puisez dans votre imagination la plus
folle vous y trouverez peut-être pas me
rater
[Musique]
jack wilshere mon affection
c'est une crue madame vols jusqu'à c
[Musique]
jodie fisher monde
patenaude
[Musique]
cave in situ république tu vas les
petits wagonlit s'appuie jarry
alors enfin pour une potiche
attends tu vas voir c'est l'ami
corbillon étaient ils adorent ça
non c'est pas vrai ça suffit plus de
xbox fait acheter les céréales forêt
avec les mauvais official après sois
gentille et calvin
je suis maman plus télé plus taipei
pyjama party plus des séries puis de jeu
avec mon frère est forcément un autre
moyen
moi je suis sûr qu'il y aura maman
certains même la réforme maintenant faut
pas m'énerver
[Musique]
chérie
sally aux mondieux manquants
un record
[Musique]
c'est une chance
dépêchez vous c'est mort quand
[Musique]
[Rires]
allez allez dunaire vous êtes encore
plus longue des escarpins
[Musique]
monsieur
david ouvre les portes kabyle qui a
ouvert les portes il vous plait d'accord
kelvin tu as gagné une fois de plus faux
pas m'énerver
calvin windham trapil
qu'est ce que j'ai dit qu'ils allaient
tarifs et si tu continues est de faire
des gribouillages sur ta table vous
faites une interro là la réponse à la
question était que tu allais nettoyer
toutes les tables pendant la récréation
alors vous allez tous vous lever et me
chantait la bannière étoilée à toi
calvin allez tu commences pourquoi c'est
toujours sur moi que ça tombe à ça à
vous autres général crapules au
s'épanouit
[Musique]
cela m'ennuie mais je vais devoir être
honnête avec vous je crois que calvin
devient de plus en plus ingérable pour
notre école croyez-moi nous le savons on
ne sait vraiment plus comment le prendre
ni moi ni ma femme c'est un véritable
enfer chez nous et nous l'avons déjà
puni tellement de fois nous ne savons
plus quoi faire d'autre ça valait moment
alors j'ai pensé à tout cela
dernièrement et c'est pour cette raison
que je vous ai demandé de venir
aujourd'hui
peut-être bien
peut-être bien que tout ce dont calvin
besoin c'est d'un changement de décor un
endroit où il peut simplement prendre un
bol d'air et en finir une bonne fois
pour toute avec cette accumulation de
bêtises il ya une colonie de vacances
qui ouvre ses portes la semaine
prochaine
je pensais que peut-être vous pourriez
en profiter pour y envoyer kelvin pour
les vacances d'été
oui
les colonies de vacances donne aux
enfants l'opportunité de prendre des
responsabilités qu'ils refusent de
prendre à l'école ou à la maison et me
croiront ce qu'ils voudront mais parfois
ce sont les enfants qui ont besoin
d'espacé de temps loin de leurs parents
alors seriez vous capable de passer un
été c'est-à-dire deux mois sans votre
fils calvin
[Musique]
et bien si scoop
je suis désolé mort quand tu as eu une
récidive alors il n'y a pas de danger
imminent mais à la longue comme dans le
passé la tumeur peut grossir et les les
convulsions peuvent devenir plus
fréquentes
je sais ce que tu ensemble par rapport à
la chimio mais c'est le seul moyen de
s'en sortir il faut que tu me donnes
autre chose michael je ne vais pas
recommencer la chimio on est revenu à la
case départ
non ce n'est pas vrai on a gagné 5
années et et tu va mieux maintenant
comment s'achever mieux tu n'as pas
sauvé tu n'a fait que reculer l'échéance
signé la science s'améliore les
traitements s'améliore écoute c'est un
chemin long et difficile oui mais ne
rien faire du tout c'est vraiment
beaucoup plus grave
tous les rêves de ses petits kilos en
tête
marc grand pour moi tu n'es pas qu'un
patient
tu es mon ami et je veux que tu guérisse
alors ne me parle pas de chimie je veux
que tu me parle d'espoir et de miracle
qu'est ce qui se passe michael tu ne
crois pas aux miracles
- je crois en la médecine et il faut que
tu y crois un peu aussi
[Musique]
je n'ose pas imaginer ce que tu doit
ressentir mon gant et je ne sais pas ce
que tu veux faire mais il ya une chose
que je sais qu importe la décision
je veux vraiment que tu saches que je
serai avec toi jusqu'au bout
[Musique]
[Rires]
tu es croire tout l'islam moi tu n'oses
en éveil
elle était tueur
[Musique]
dans un anneau
m
honte à vous
un show année
michael je voulais juste dire que morgon
a décidé de s'en aller un petit bout de
temps et je suis d'accord avec lui à
cent pour cent mais alors combien de
temps en compte il être absent deux
petits mois
mais enfin le cancer n'attend pas et tu
le sais lawrence et sais je sais mais il
est parti ce matin
il voulait il voulait que je te le
disent parce qu'il savait tout allait
bien d'empêcher qu'ils voyaient bien sûr
que je leur empêchait de partir écoute
je me fiche de savoir où il va ou ce
qu'il fait je sais ce qu'il ya de mieux
pour lui lorraine et vraiment je
n'arrive pas à comprendre sa décision
comme ça à michael il ne nous demande
pas d'être d'accord avec lui il ne veut
il ne veut pas qu'on le comprenne
oui de toute évidence il ne sait pas ce
dont il a besoin voici
ce qu'il veut
c'est que quand ils reviennent ou soit
là tous les deux pour lui
je m'excuse le règne j'aimerais pas
forcément ça c'est que je suis enceinte
[Musique]
j'allais lui dire l'autre matin et puis
je les retrouver dans la salle de bains
allongée et
c'était impossible quand on parle du
loup on en voit l'accueil c'est lauren
ça le shérif t'as pas grandir année non
j'ai pas commis cette erreur
[Rires]
[Musique]
à
au prix louga vouloir nous excuser pour
ce retard d'accompagner son équipe et je
vous souhaite un agréable séjour dans
les cas du minnesota et vous recommencez
l'a donc voici le dossier de chacun des
enfants ton chalet des apaches tu as un
groupe assez exceptionnel bien la
dernière chose que je veux c'est un
groupe de fauteurs de troubles
[Musique]
ok j'ai marqué ce qui fait grossir you
c'est tout
[Musique]
quelle poisse notion de soul rap
tranquille j'ai adoré mon là l'un des
enfants l'un des enfants et mes bouts
somers
les parents se sont noyés emportés par
une vague sur la côte du maine
ouais ils ont retrouvé bout deux jours
après il attendait toujours ses parents
ça fait plus d'un an il n'a pas dit un
mot depuis
[Musique]
l'aurore boréale tu te souviens de cette
nuit j'ai beaucoup pensé ces derniers
temps
[Musique]
pourquoi tout d'un coup je me sens
nerveux
parce que tant de gamins d'à coups c'est
loin d'être évident tu pense que je suis
fou way est venu que l'appel
[Musique]
le
nouvelles baskets
ouais elle était désolée je m'appelle
ryan tucker salut ryan crocker
cet été je suis ton moniteur vous êtes
le moniteur des apaches vous c'est ça
bon alors très bien sûr il ya ma maman
qui m'a dit vous dire que je ne
participerai à aucune bagarre et que je
ne mettrai pas en colère et que de tout
l'été je ne dirai absolument aucun gros
mot
regardez ya pas de pingouins gays la vap
faire salle cuba - parce qu'en fait si
je maintiens très bien
mon père dit qu'il me donnera un matelas
à eau
[Musique]
au gazole et monsieur vous allez bien
ouais ça va aller ça va alors bonne
journée
[Musique]
le chalet des apaches just matic
c'est bon
[Musique]
e
voyez sortie annoncée mois hors de
question je vais tirer à mon père
sir charles winthrop le navet le cas
d'air piscine
[Musique]
bah c'est année c'est la tétée est tous
morts qui n'en font qu'un
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qui attend un problème du make
way tafas ou bien est-ce que c'était
fait
[Musique]
tu t'appelles comment
salubre
[Musique]
dis moi ce que tu as fait à charles
c'est lui qui m'a provoqué maintenant je
rentrais nom et vous vous êtes un peu
vieux pour être moniteur tu fais ça à la
maison
ouais et à l'école aussi
eh ben la prochaine fois que tu agis
comme un chien j'te fair nous fêtons
pipi des gains de mon espace limaces
c'est quoi ça c'est pour qu'ils osent
[Musique]
ils avaient besoin d'être l'achat des
troncs c'est abriteront bon je vais
chercher charlie je compte sur vous
pouvez faire vos bagages et faire vos
lycées caire et c'est ça
ce n'est moins n'auraient pas vu anne
des apaches l'aurait dans un coin laisse
moi t'expliquer les règles du cache
cache ici si tu arrêtes de les chercher
ils arrêtent de se cacher très drôle
je te conseille de faire en sorte qu'ils
soient déjà installés avant de manger si
l'antenne y sera longue et or est
inquiète je gère la situation
c'est du solide
[Musique]
est-ce que ça va il y as matic bond et
sans peter pan et toi regarde moi
écoutez moi bien vous devait m'appeler
chef et cet été votre moniteur c'est moi
je veux vous leviez la main quand vous
entendez votre nom brian tucker george
clinton
calvin murray booth somers same sun is
et charles winthrop qui manquent à
l'appel
cet endroit est une porcherie je veux
que vous ramassez vos affaires et
voulait ranger immédiatement et quand je
vous dirais quelque chose là projecteurs
[Musique]
ça va être un été très long chef très
bien je de gens c'est ici que le village
du corbeau se mettre en rang avant tout
les repas nom de ce jeu il est très
facile à retenir
il s'appelle la propre décompte
vous allez être choisi par ordre de
présentation le dernier chalet appelé
sera le dernier chalet être servis à
table
c'est quoi ça revienne
ça c'est rare entre tes mains plus forte
je peux essayer
ouais mais ils sont très durs d'accord
comme ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
asseyez-vous silence on se calme calvin
murray chez les apaches va faire la
prière à l'est et plus vite que ça bouge
ton boule
la prochaine fois je me vengerai tu veux
en choisir une dent livre non ça va je
peux en réciter une à moi s'il vous
plaît c'est la préférée de mon père bien
sûr majt aviron des matches là bien
comme ça tp ne sentiront rien
c'est pas très bon pour qu'elle veille
c'était très beau nyan win
la prière est un moment sacré au
remercie dieu pour notre repas il ya
beaucoup de gens qui meurent de faim
dans le monde vous ne comprenez ouais
ben j'en fais partie à l'est où la
bouffe dans la pub elle fait attention à
ton langage c'est pour vous les filles
retournent si ta maman t'es mort là
lesquels de ces singes va faire péter la
tronche je t'arrête la prochaine fois
qu'il sera tout seul cas vie super des
nouilles à la sauce gerbe ckoi chef des
nouilles à la sauce aigre-douce
l'associé gros douce c'est quoi ça
matamec c'est mal élevé je te vois faire
ça encore une fois jeune homme est pas
de ma classe quoi tout ce que je voulais
c'est que ce gars là prennent une bonne
manière
le gars tous d'or et que ça saute pour
quoi faire j'ai pas envie maintenant dû
rester chez vous
c'est ça quand c'est ce pour quoi revoir
[Musique]
ecoutez-moi lia ya un gros bourdon et
nous sommes une équipe le chalet des
apaches quand l'un de nous se fait
toucher on est tous touchés avec faites
comme si vous étiez les six
mousquetaires un pour tous et tous pour
un compris et mettez vous un petit peu à
la place debout
[Musique]
oh
arrête ryan à l'effet passé charlie tu
m'avais dit que je pourrais jouer jouer
avec toi même claude denis
josh c'est quoi ça c'est mythique
excellent il te sucent le sang pareil
que moustiques coule pas cool
et pourquoi ça les tic sont connus comme
porteur de beaucoup de maladies la
maladie de lyme
le crs la grippe aviaire la méningite
les hépatites l'éléphantiasis les
hémorroïdes
la gonorrhée hémorroïdes trois mois t'as
pas envie d'en trouver une
la wau cette petite bestiole peut faire
tout ça si la main calvin en baisse dato
n'arrête ryan matelas à eau
merci chef au fait qu'elles reviennent
les bonnes ici le matin c'est toi la
bonne et c'est charles quoi vous devrez
faire votre lit tous les matins et faire
en sorte que la maison soit en ordre et
ça vaut pour tout le monde mais je ne
sais pas sur mon lit enfin ben les grand
temps que tu apprennes mais moi je ne
suis pas comme vous un pour tous et tous
pour un chat et chef pourquoi ce que lui
il dit rien je ne sais pas quel vide
peut-être qu'un jour nous le dira en
attendant plus de jeux vidéo plus de
lampes torches les gars
et plus de bla bla vous avez une longue
journée devant vous demain donc tout le
monde les aplats bonne nuit les gars boy
f et bout pourquoi tu dis jamais rien
toi
mac là où matelas ou mais quoi qu'est ce
que j'ai dit à propos de la violence
je sors maintenant jusqu'à ce que je
vais te chercher
[Musique]
tu veux aller à l'infirmerie
on y va aller et vous fait bouffer par
les moustiques ne bouge pas d'un poil
jusqu'à ce que je revienne
arrête de faire semblant toi t'es pas
censé être dehors toi tu me fait trop
peur je suis venu chercher ma [ __ ] à
mouches et je vais commencer par toi moi
mauviettes
allez hop
dommage
c'est son dossier de l'an passé ils
étaient là
[Musique]
hypocondriaque
non non non non ça sonne gaston vous
faites donc qu'est ce que tu fais je
déteste charles et sa thune explique
comment c'est exactement ce que je vais
lui faire ce que je vais faire avec toi
tu internet ressaisir yann je te renvoie
illico presto chez des parents
[Musique]
bien quoi
j'ai quelque chose à contrer
[Musique]
c'est une chauve souris frugivores elles
n'attaquent pas les humains
en plus toi qui te plaignais des
moustiques
cette petite et à meilleur ami parce
qu'elle peut en manger des milliers
toutes les nuits
c'est aussi un mammifère et une vertèbre
et donc qu'elle ressent la douleur et
elle a mal
et comme quand toi tu étais bébé
ces bébés ont besoin de leur mère pour
survivre tous les êtres vivants ont leur
place dans la nature ariane
réfléchi à ce que ta colère peut
provoquer
[Musique]
et gestes
comment je peux l'aider tu peux l'aider
en te laissant plus aller à la colère
je m'excuse chef
bonne nuit
[Musique]
salut chef
ils sont horribles ouais tu finiras par
t'habituer comme pour les verrues on
était si différent d'eux
c'est bon de t'avoir parmi nous on a
passé deux chouettes moments dans ce cas
pas tu te souviens dommage qu'on puisse
pas rester enfant pour toujours ça fait
partie de mon problème il ya une partie
de moi qui a envie de redevenir un petit
garçon tu sais autant je croyais à
l'éternité
on en revient toujours au même point un
chiffre l'aurore boréale
[Musique]
je n'ai jamais oublié cette nuit ce
n'est quand on s'était perdu dans cette
forêt
j'ai jamais eu aussi peur jusqu'à la tan
on a eu de la chance qui nous est
retrouvé
ça peut te sembler bizarre est sonnée
mais je sais que tout ça a un rapport
avec l'europe au real quand ces lumières
sont sortis dans le ciel il nous est
arrivé quelque chose on n'avait plus
peur tu te souviens
on savait qu'on allait s'en sortir j'ai
pas trop
on était juste de gosses terrorisés
c'était peut-être notre imagination
[Musique]
peut-être
mais tu vois
j'ai besoin de croire que tout va bien
se passer
j'ai besoin d'un miracle
[Musique]
sheikh lorraine
aujourd'hui j'ai compris qu'on avait
beau vouloir tout emmené quand on part
en voyage le coeur reste toujours auprès
de la personne aimée
j'espère qu'avec le temps je trouverais
ce que je cherche j'ai peur que tu ne
saches pas à quel point tu comptes dans
ma vie
les enfants dorment et je te jure qu'ils
ont l'air de six petits anges mais la
pensée de les réveiller demain matin me
donne la chair de poule
hermann mais comme as tu donc fait myrna
c'est la fécondité herman ton sperme est
en moi maintenant c'est herman et myrna
et moi à tout à leur vieux sage rabougri
[Musique]
arrêté de caresser le porte
or jour chefs et chefs avec la chauve
souris on fait quoi
rien mais souviens toi notre
conversation d'hier soir vous pouvez
compter sur moi merci beaucoup
derrien attention moi arrêtez de claquer
cette forte
on cherche f voilà c'est ça mais assez
qu'est ce que vous avez dit chef j'ai
dit merci de fermer la porte gentil moi
à me dit rien
[Musique]
qu'est ce qu'il ya
à
[Musique]
debout belle au bois dormant c'est
l'heure du petit déj lui la grasse
matinée
salut charles tu n'es plus chez toi ce
matin soyez sport chef et apportez moi
mon petit déjeuner vous voulez bien
il y aura un bon pourboire pour voir et
bien voici ton pour toi c'est ce que tu
arriveras à chaque fois que tu ne te
lèveras pas quand la cloche sonnera
allez debout duster williams du chalet
des iroquois va faire la prière
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et on se calme pour notre santé notre
force et notre repas quotidiens nous
vous remercions mon dieu calvin
ça c'était une vraie prière sané tu
réalises à calvin s'est inscrit ce matin
[Musique]
viennent réfléchi à ce que t'a collé le
provoquer
[Musique]
d'accord j'ai hâte en jeu ne pas voir et
attends je suis plus en colère jeudi
attendait c'était pas josh lui il est
bon oui
[Musique]
giorgi c'est toi
[Applaudissements]
au secours et devoirs
et tu t'es laver les cheveux comme
demandé oui deux fois tes cheveux ont
l'air drôlement sec pour avoir été lavé
deux fois vous avez raison chef c'est
possible que je les îles avec une fois
et sportif pas vraiment ouais j'ai comme
des espèces de tension man hulk
j'ai comme des gonflements dans mes
ligaments croisés antérieurs et ça fait
très mal
pourquoi tu te mets du déodorant t'as
même pas encore de poils sous les bras
ça n'a rien à voir avec ça ouais mais
pourquoi tu tenue de ce truc la puberté
la puberté mec tu te fiches de moi t'es
pas encore pu faire si je suis non tu
n'es pas qu'est ce que t'en sais et bien
pour commencer
t'as aucun poil sur ton cornichons mais
enfin ça n'a rien à voir mais alors
qu'est ce qu'il ya à voir respecte moi
je peux pas vraiment expliquer mais
t'inquiète tu seras quand ça tu
arriveras et comment tu sais que ça mais
pas déjà arrivé au crois moi ce n'est
pas le cas qu'est ce que t'en fais et
bien premièrement tu ne mets pas de
déodorant et j'y pense je crois bien que
j'ai une hernie discale aussi dans le
dos
et en plus de tout ça qui m'a poussé une
sorte de glandes sébacées sous la peau
une quoi vous savez hippiques saint pie
v go chef qu'est ce que c'est que cette
paix tu dis encore une fois ce mot et tu
dors dehors alors c'est quoi cette salle
puberté tu m'en occupe chef la puberté
ryan s'est simplement l'étape décisive
dans le développement humain où l'homme
et la femme sont capables de
reproduction via le sexe tu vas fermer
ok tout le monde au lit les lumières
devrait est éteinte depuis une heure
vous allez nous chanter une chanson chef
pas juste une chanson ça m'etonne un
classique mais seulement seulement si
vous promettez de vous coucher tout de
suite mesuré
ok alors si vous connaissez les paroles
vous gênez pas d'accord
[Musique]
pif
la petite voiture a perdu savent où son
ami noir ça c'est puéril
oui j'ai changé je ne savais pas du led
zeppelin ouais ouais
plus d'un sur la
josh tu penses faire quoi de ce mais
qu'est ce que tu viens de sortir de ton
mais t'as pas intérêt à le laisser sur
ta manche planche ça ne va pas ensemble
mickey mais qu'est pique-niqué mikami
que mikami kabyle communiqué qu'est ce
que tu vas faire de ce week-end je vais
t'expliquer une chose je te conseille
pas de manger même si c'est sucré parce
que c'est plat de chair
mais gaby
qu'est ce que tu vas faire de ce quick
est juteux murray fait t'as pas intérêt
à faire une pichenette
sinon ça risquerait de provoquer la
guerre mais j'ai mieux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
niquet
[Musique]
on
à sarov
[Musique]
m
dames
[Musique]
le soir
chat
[Musique]
soirée
zuma
[Musique]
chaque
salut salut ya quelque chose pour moi
vraiment chef c'est la peine de demander
vous recevez plus de pâques et que les
campeurs merci beaucoup plus salée mon
chef
c'est un petit clin d'oeil pour que vous
sachiez que je pense à vous tous dit à
josh de ne pas s'inquiéter et n'eurent
aucun fruit sac
j'ai hâte de te retrouver à la maison la
semaine prochaine je t'aime lorraine
c'est quoi ta ligne
quant à quelque chose qui tombe pas rond
et que ça bien de ton bidon ok pas de
décès d'accord alors vous vous tenez
bien durant le reste du repas je reviens
tout de suite
dix bons appelé [ __ ]
[Musique]
et toi les rouages
hahaha
à
non
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
k
rappaz
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
d'où ce bond à la guitare
[Musique]
tu sais il ne se passe pas un jour sans
que je me souvienne de toutes les
conneries qu'on a fait ici toi et moi
amen mon frère je crois que je suis prêt
à agir est tous a maintenant sonné j'ai
retrouvé le peps qu'est ce que tu veux
dire j'ai fui la réalité en venant ici
parce que j'étais pas prêt à affronter
tout ça et c'est la pire chose à propos
du cancer
c'est que ça détruit le mental ça
détruite à force vitale maintenant c'est
comme si j'avais besoin d'une nouvelle
raison de vivre pour pouvoir avancer
heureusement que j'ai leur règne dans ma
vie c'est elle qui m'a dit de revenir
ici
elle savait que je ne supporterais pas
que je ne trouverai aucune réponse en
restant là bas rome lamentant sur mon
sort
alors qu'est ce qui t'a fait changer ses
petits monstres
chaque fois que je regarde le visage
jeune je vois leur énergie
je vois la vie dans leurs cieux
et c'est beau
oh
il me rappelle que tout ça en vaut
vraiment la peine et j'aimerais les
amener chez moi la semaine prochaine ils
sont comme ma femme et ses chefs tu peux
à voir ta propre finir
ouais je sais
lauren et moi en avons beaucoup parlé
j'étais du genre à penser que ce n'était
pas juste de mettre au monde un enfant
dans ces circonstances du voile
maintenant
qui sait
[Musique]
j
qu'est ce qui est si drôle je comprends
maintenant pourquoi tu es toujours ici
on sent comme un enfant dans cet endroit
ouais ça doit être terrible pour toi un
terrible pourquoi c'est à peu près au
même âge concilie à main que tu t'es
fait défoncer la tronche on pas par toi
en tout cas aller chef leroy du lac
franchement ça témoin à côté scott a été
le roi du la mémoire courte
le premier qui arrive de louper
[Musique]
et chef mauro vignolo voir sa visite
allez les gars j'ai appelé à table en
premier on a quoi en échange
eh bien je ferai vous lis rangerez le
chalet demain j'ai conclu allez allez
qu'est ce qui vous arrive les gars on
est toujours le dernier c'est lassant et
où elle chef
dommage qu'il rate alesi a passé waouh
bras bien trop cool
tap la calvin gagner gagner galère
c'était pas très sympa de faire ça au
chef calvin chef vous avez raté ça on
était à leur revient
[Musique]
cette formalité
j'ai chef
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
il va s'en sortir le chef oui il va s'en
sortir
et vous savez quoi je crois que c'est le
moment de vous raconter une petite
histoire sur sony est le chef
il ya quelques années plus que vous ne
pouvez l'imaginer
le chef et moi on était les ferrato
encadré
[Musique]
mes parents
alors ça va ouais les crises est rien
elles font plus peur qu'autre chose je
vais pas bien je vais pas y arriver et
ce au nez c'est plus fort que moi je
crois qu'il est temps de rentrer
lauren manque tellement
[Musique]
allo excusez moi qui s'est dit plus que
je suis au chalet du chef les bus
oui oui je le prends mademoiselle
roberts c'est moi qui ai rendu le chef
malade je suis désolé kelvin jeu
je ne sais pas ce que tu as fait mais
qu'est ce qu'il lui arrive
je tu sais je ne peux pas vraiment
expliquer mais sony a raison shell pas
s'en sortir c'est pas ta faut tirer
en fait j'ai parlé au chef toutes à
l'arrêt et il retourne quand ce soir
j'ai trouvé une lettre que le chef vous
a écrit et je crois que je commets l'une
des raisons de sa maladie
[Musique]
quand est-ce que tu pars
après le petit déj
je dirai au revoir aux enfants au petit
matin il aura beau real alors hein
tu avais raison sony on n'était que de
gamin a terrorisé non j'ai fait c'était
réel
[Musique]
on
if chez les lakers c'est l'heure de
partir
ali où est ce qu'on va
[Musique]
et qui va encore compte et la placera
yens qu'est ce qui se passe les gars il
se passe qu'on va aller voir l'aurore
boréale et vous venez à vue que nous
chefs
ouais ouais ouais désolé les gars mais
comme tu peux le voir chef
les canoës sont tous là elles sont prêts
à y aller sonner les gosses rentrer chez
eux ce week-end il faut qu'ils préparent
leurs bagages d'être venu d'un coup quoi
c'était mon idée chef remplissent je ne
suis pas certaine que ses enfants vont
se contenter d'un nom
[Musique]
et chef a pour tous et tous pour un où
est le chef
partagez et mais c'était dur tu vois
ryan c'est exactement ce dont je te
parlais l'autre jour si vraiment tu
étais pubères tu pourrais gérer ça tu
vas la fermer charme
j'y vais seulement si tu viens avec nous
c'est ton voyage je serai ici à tourtour
merci se dit salut les gars ils ceux de
derrière et devant la prison et à mon
nom
attention à l'art on arrive quand wayne
est vrai qu'en c'est vous qui vouliez
partir vous avez un trou de mémoire
ouais bon là d'où je viens moi tous les
bateaux ont des moteurs
aïe mais qu'est ce que je t'ai fait au
[Musique]
merci mec
vous pouvez nager l'otan ya des requins
dans l'eau
[Musique]
non
barca c'est quoi ce truc c'est une
tortue flottante
c'est le cadeau et c'est saxon ah ouais
c'est ça tu vas tout ça tu comprendras
trouver un mec tout ça grêle dopé revers
m
[Musique]
séduits chef salue tout va bien
jf
est-ce que vous allez mourir
[Musique]
de serre comme mon père était mort en je
vais poser la même question
il m'a dit personne ne survit à cette
maladie et je ne m'attends pas être le
premier et les marchés oui
il est mort je suis désolé merci petit
vous avez peur oui parfois
[Musique]
faux pas non papa d'et toujours il ya
une première fois pour tous
[Musique]
je
parti dont c'est dingue on se réveille
laborde j'aime bien vous allez bien
debout casting au chef
on s'est endormi à la belle étoile c'est
super joli ici j'avais carrément trop
beau les gars tu n'es pas cessé tant
dans sa part un joli vraiment oui oui
chef
neymar ça pas besoin les gars c'est moi
qu'il est gravé ya trente ans de ça
sony et moi on était dans le chalet des
apaches en 1981 on coule on est parti en
canoë avec tous les autres enfants et en
fait on s'est laissé distancer
vous vous êtes perdu ouais et vous êtes
allés où est ben heureusement on avait
une tentes et de la nourriture et c'est
ici qu'on a atterri vous aviez pas la
trouille
ah oui on avait la trouille et cette
nuit là pendant qu'on était assis sur la
falaise l'aurore boréale est apparu
celui nous a raconté tous h f
c'est comme un arc en ciel nocturne oui
c'est vrai c'est ça mais cette nuit là
quelque chose d'incroyable s'est passé
et bien c'est difficile à expliquer mais
on était assis là haut sur la falaise
ils faisaient tout noir on était
terrorisé comme jamais et puis tout d'un
coup dans le ciel sont apparus des
lumières incroyablement brillante est de
toutes les couleurs
[Musique]
un jour vous aussi vous pourrez
peut-être les voir ses lumières les gars
si vous voulez mais on veut les voir
maintenant c'est pour ça qu'on est ici
et elles vont venir ce soir chef à ça on
sait jamais mais ce soir c'est notre
dernière nuit si jamais elles ne
viennent pas ouais ouais
oui quitte mon chef alors peut-être
quand vous reviendrai l'année prochaine
je veux pas rentrer à la maison c'est
tout dire c'est vrai c'est la première
fois de toute ma vie que je me fais rien
interdire du tout ouais c'est vrai mon
joueur gilmar entrée non plus oui vous
savez les gars je crois qu'il va falloir
qu'on installe des tentes car il va
pleuvoir ce soir c'est à mon tour action
vérité vérité alors tu as déjà embrassé
une fille bien sûr hockey à mon tour
c'est vrai oui alors ok à mon tour
action ou fait un french kiss j'en ai
aucune idée du genre de qu'est ce que
c'était est ce que vous vous êtes
embrasser avec la langue
ok laisse tomber désolé bout mais je
dormirai pas à côté ce pervers
tous aux abris j'ai dit non aux abris
arrête de péter peut rien les flageolets
ça me fait toujours ça arrête de me
postillonne ac soutien et c'est ça
qu'est ce que c'est
tu charbon du charbon ça empêche de
péter au passé
tiens-toi ryan tu vas me donner de
l'asthme
e
non
[Musique]
elle
à
ans
richesse on pense qu'ils sont là oui
aller mais je n'ai rien vous venez venez
voir jeu
[Musique]
non
e
m
à
[Musique]
e
m
[Musique]
est ce que c'est vrai
ça c'est pas si mal passé et un chef est
bon on fait baver tout l'été ces gamins
ouais mais ils ont passé de bons moments
et c'est bien ça le principal c'est
triste chef dans ce camp on nous
refourgue tous les enfants un problème
mais j'ai appris à bien un temps qu'en
rassemblant toutes les couleurs ont fait
un arc en ciel vide
bobby ryan a nui josh manu same sun
au niveau
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
robbie avec un creux jamais 75 pc
bonne nuit bout
[Musique]
on va vous manquer oh oui sûrement
bon
ça y est merci pour tout chef c'était le
meilleur était tout mali pour moi aussi
dire
et il reviendra l'année prochaine ouais
bien sûr faut quelqu'un pour surveiller
tous ces petits gars
au revoir chef toi aussi tu vas me
manquer
a+ y est vrai on se voit les prochaines
[Musique]
comme de par la loi
s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
cher monsieur et madame de coeur ryan ne
s'est battu à aucun moment n'a provoqué
absolument personne ne s'est imposé
je vais te coller et n'a dit aucun gros
mot
eni dit de grossièretés cet été alors si
vous êtes d'accord je suis évidemment
pour que ryan est un matelas il le
mérite il le mérite
[Musique]
cordialement chef merci j'ai fait et
rayhana tombe chef vous êtes un chic
type
merci charles tu t'en sors pas mal non
plus et de temps en temps je pourrai
vous appelez écrit moi c'est moins cher
c'est pas moderne
j'ai un téléphone avec forfait minutes
illimité et tu m'appelleras aussi bien
sûr on fera un appel conférence avec le
chef a mis au bien sûr mec
salut les gars et ryan
[Musique]
merci mais trop cool
merci de m'avoir ouvert les yeux
un jeu d'enfant en charge et au revoir
e
[Musique]
en fait chauffeur je peux aller devant
avez-vous g ennuyeux d'être tout seul
derrière
ce sera avec plaisir monsieur à partir
de maintenant
appelez-moi chat
[Musique]
d'accord charles
et ça me famille à moi
[Musique]
hé les gars vous partez sans dire au
revoir
j'ai grand chef tempe et la haye
faut pas énerver le chef ar vous l'avez
intégré
[Musique]
au revoir
des jeunes
vous allez manquer
[Musique]
qui fait quoi samba
je voulais te dire mais oui mais ça lui
tu en sais
[Musique]
s
vous pouvez attendre une minute
mon petit frère va bientôt sortir de la
maison c'est son premier jour des
corolla non tu connais les règles calvin
soit tu montes soit cours bon alors
allez on va le rattraper
[Musique]
produits
il
avec qui
m